think about if you had all the resources
in the world okay
and say you have 10 billion in the bank
and you're at a point you've traveled
the world
you have kids you're 59 years old zooby
king zubi you're 59 years old you got 10
billion in a bangle beautiful wife your
kids have done your kids are doing great
they love you life is good married happy
everything you're politically making an
impact you've done great for yourself
and then you're seeing a big league in
education
and if you chose to start a university
how would you start that university and
what would you teach what would be your
format because there is a leak in it and
there is experience in there's a big
difference between us doing the podcast
this way
versus us doing a podcast on a zoom
you're sitting right here in flesh i'm
sitting right here on flesh we're having
this conversation it's a little bit more
intimate versus hey zooby so how are
things
so that there is that intimate
experience so if you have 10 billion and
all of a sudden you get the itch and you
say you know what i just think you know
we do need a university i do think we
need to do something there there's a way
of doing it better how would you do it
better i have some ideas i'm curious on
how you guys would do it better that's a
great question i mean the first thing i
would do is have this conversation with
smart people in different fields
successful you know people in the world
of
science and law talk to doctors talk to
people like yourself entrepreneurs and
see okay what
we've been running with this system for
for centuries right the world has
changed massively in each person's field
and sector let's have this conversation
and see okay like what would what would
what would you want to teach what do you
think would be valuable ask that of
different people and then over time i
would i wouldn't put it all on myself
and think you know oh no i'll see your
horse i i have the knowledge of all
these you know i just but even for you
just for you like ideally for you like
okay so for example um
you know uh
you know like you you you start a
restaurant okay
and if we're starting a restaurant
together the four of us first thing
let's just say okay what do we want to
do do we want to make it a niche what do
you mean is it sushi if it's sushi we're
doing sushi if it's you know american
we're doing burgers okay we're doing
that if we're doing italian we're doing
italian if we're doing are we doing a
mixture are we doing like a uh
fusion is that what we're gonna be doing
okay let's just say we're doing a fusion
what's the fusion between let's say
we're doing peruvian and chinese food
combined like chino chiclano by jose
andres okay we're doing a
fusion of mexican food and you know uh
whatever food perfect that's where you
took me in vegas that's what you're
coming up with
in dc vegas is poblano pomano's mexican
and chinese okay so then we make a menu
and we say what do you like on the menu
you say i like these seven things to eat
what do you like i like these nine
things tom what do you like i like these
six things tyler what do you like i like
these eight things we add it then we
look at the list and we say guys
which one of these can we eliminate
and one by one by when we eliminate and
we keep the top
40 of the items on the menu that we all
love okay i think the first step is take
all the topics yes that are teaching and
look at it and say uh which one of these
you're going to use in your life yes
okay
and i want to say
okay let's take the top 20 percent of
things that we are going to use okay
and then let's add new things that
nobody else is teaching to it business
entrepreneurship negotiation sales money
let's add this to it right fitness
health and fitness let's add this to a
diet like that kind of stuff let's add
this to it and let's go with it and by
the way if you want to study philosophy
go to university of whatever if you want
to study this go over there our school
is to teach you stuff that you're going
to apply in your life and then here's
what makes us unique adam what's that
two things number one 50 of our um
professors are former operators what do
you mean
it's a form of a contribution to society
hey adam you're 63 you've made a lot of
money
you don't need to make another 50
million bucks are you willing to
contribute six hours of your week to
society yeah what do i need to do a
class a day for one hour
i can do a class every other day no
problem let's start off with that adam
is now a professor teaching basics of
money because he became financially free
but he's not talking as a guy that
desperately needs the salary he's
talking from a guy that's worth 10
million dollars here's how i did it
these are the mistakes that i made right
okay zooby your topic is going to be
this how do you want to can you are you
willing to contribute to success guys i
can only do two hours a week no problem
it's fine here's what we're gonna do
then my format will be the following
format
in topics that there needs to be a lot
of debate the class would have two
professors not one professor
if we're doing religious studies i'm
gonna have a christian and i'm gonna
have a whatever pick another uh uh
denomination or not denomination
religion muslim put catholicism
mormonism judaism pick them okay
and that's what it is so you debate and
i debate and i'm the student i'm an
amateur the entire time because i'm like
what a freaking format you're sitting
there teaching history have couple
people debate that every class would
have two professors not one and the
format would be debate because i think
what we're saying here with universities
i think if a university like that
existed i would love for my kids to go
there like the idea has got to be dude i
am so
happy my kids are in your hands thank
you i'm so happy my kids are in your
hands i was
at a wedding uh
last november
and at the wedding the father the guy
that was getting married shows up to me
and he gives me a hug and he starts
crying he says listen man i'm so glad
you got a hold of my son at 18 years old
because it because the teaching the
environment
changed so
i have kids i know eventually these kids
got to go learn from somebody else for
me to be able to say my son is spending
a quarter with tom i'm like it's coming
from a place of dude that kid is going
to come better so the idea of education
for parents needs to be
i can't wait to meet the final product
of my daughter or my son
but that's not the feeling today so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]